Hola a todos, bienvenidos a la siguiente clase. Vamos a continuar con el trabajo que
vemos que ha dado un triunfo pendiente. Así que voy a hacer lo siguiente. Venimos acá y
decimos lo siguiente. Muy aparte de estos, existe lo que son también webhooks. Un webhook
netamente es un sistema que puede darnos una información, una actualización o una alerta
de que estamos recibiendo un mensaje. Por ejemplo, un webhook es donde generalmente se puede
interpretar procesos como cuesta cuando ustedes pagan el banco, generalmente los que ganan una
notificación. Esa aspecto sí o sí se tiene que notificar. Ahora puede haber webhooks que
traen un montón de tiempo, mucho depende del tipo de proyecto que hagan, pero siempre
mesas las alertas. Cuando me dice su solicitud ha sido completada o recibió 2000 bolivianos de
tal pago y listo. Voy a añadir esto. Vamos a añadir un webhook ahí. No lo voy a conectar todavía.
Puedo hacerlo así, diríamos. No hay lío para que ya trabaje con los webhooks. Ahora paso a otro
punto también, que en este caso voy a tratar de utilizar algunos aspectos más técnicos. Por
ejemplo, acá. Hay algo también interesante. Un modelo de ya no solamente puede preenprenerse
con modelos previos o con ya proms realizados como hemos hecho anterior clase. Aquí podemos
trabajar ya también con la parte de. Apis, nuestras bases de dato y demás. Podemos procesar varios
aspectos técnicos para evitar luego tener problemas a futuro. En para eso, yo voy a trabajar
netamente con lo siguiente. Ancliga acá. Y aquí van a trabajar con http requests. Estos pueden
manejar los tools. Listo, lo voy a cerrar acá uno. Pueden sacarse varios. Ya no es necesario con uno
nomás. Yo voy a sacar dos o uno para el proceso. Voy a colocar uno de trigger y voy a colocar http
requests. Listo, ya tengo otro digamos. Esta parte no perdón. Yo me estoy equivocando. De aquí tienen
que clicar acá. Y esto lo hará. Ya lo cerramos y también puede enjala en este caso de bases de
dato. Ya. Podemos trabajar con Maya SQL. Van a colocar el tool. Y dentro de este tool lo dejamos ahí.
Pueden colocarse. En el table en Maya SQL. Ya. Lo que voy a proceder en lo siguiente.
Vamos a crear primero algunos puntos y vamos a tratar de entrarnos alguna.
Ya. Así que va a cambiar un poquito mis datos, pero vamos a trabajar con algunos puntos más
desarrollados dentro de qué tipo de APIs voy a manejar. Porque hay un montón de APIs que se puede
trabajar en la web. Ya no es necesario trabajar con webs externas o web internas. Apis también se
puede trabajar con fakes. Ya. Y esos fakes generalmente lo vamos a aplicar para que me dé algún tipo de
dato y respuesta. Ya. Así que puedo venir acá y voy a colocar lo siguiente.
Publi. Publi. Voy a colocar. Publi. Api. Creo que se llama.
Punto de esto más que todo está simulando tiendas. O sea, qué vende, digamos. Ya. Bueno,
aquí no me aparece, pero creo que tengo aquí una interfaz. A ver, voy a copiar esto.
Ya. Estos van a estar en la descripción del grupo. Va a estar ahí colocados los APIs.
Entonces aquí, por ejemplo, es una API. La voy a traducir para que se entienda. Dice.
Fakes. Terapia. Es una API. Gratuita que proporciona que es una variedad de datos
simulados para una tienda en línea. Los usuarios pueden acceder a productos,
categorías, usuarios, pedidos, ficticias para utilizarse en el desarrollo y pruebas de sus
aplicaciones. Vamos a hacer una prueba. Entonces, por eso significa que dígese. Dice. HTTPS.
Entonces yo quiero productos. A ver, porque estamos ahorita vendiendo en este caso comida para perros.
Pero voy a inventarme. Como quiero productos, puedo en este caso, esta partecita, copiarme todo el
HTTPS. Control C, control B. Me voy a ir a mi workflow. Voy a entrarme acá.
Ya. Y aquí la URL puedo pegar acá. Control B y listo. Ya tenemos ese aspecto más técnico.
Ahora para hacer pruebas alternas, pruebas externas, voy a ver acá. Lo mismo voy a copiarlo acá y me va
a aparecer un montón de dats. Bueno, ahí está un montón de productos que ya está dentro de
SAPI para colocar datos. Como les he dicho, fakes. Ya lo cierro. Ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Una vez que tenga eso, voy a decir esto. Alguna cosa más. No. Lo voy a cerrar mientras tanto.
Y acá dentro del modelo, voy a irme a sistema donde está mi sistema acá.
Academy Prom, no? En sistema aquí. Voy a agrandar esto y voy a colocar acá.
Voy a decir. Si te preguntan por nuestros productos,
ingresa ingresa a dos puntos o a voy a colocar. Voy a cerrar un cachó.
Voy a venir acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente. Voy a doble clic. Esta parte voy a cambiar lista de
productos. Listo. Y aquí igual le pueden colocar lista de productos.
Para que la I ya sepa dónde ir. Lo cierro y listo. Ya es actualizado. Vuelvo acá.
Y ahora voy a volver a mi prompt. Doble clic. Voy a irme a sistema. A lista de productos.
Producción. Si te preguntan, voy a volver a copiar esto. Si te preguntan en este caso. Por nuestros
asesores de venta. Asesores. No. Asesores. De venta. Entra o ingresa a asesores.
Voy a hacer dos prompts ya internos. Por qué? Por lo siguiente. Aquí voy a cremear a puro.
Por lo en este caso.
Osoarios. Ya. Para esa parte voy a darles igual otro otro link.
En el cuerpo al ingresar. Voy a venir acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Ya. Yo hice un place holder. Aquí por ejemplo hay igual a la piz. Pero aquí hay usuarios.
Inventé sus usuarios. Pero no importa. Conta que fotos también. Puedes hacer cualquier cosa.
Ustedes. Vengo acá. Voy a copiar este HTTP. Voy a venir a workflow. Voy a hacer doble clic acá.
Ya. Voy a pegarlo. Y esta parte voy a colocar en vez de todos users. Por qué está acá? No con
users. Barra users. Ya listo. Ya está. Enseguida colocar asesores. Aquí también asesores.
Listo. Eso sería todo. Los cerramos. Ya tendríamos eso. Ahora cuando yo le pregunte acá por el one
form submission. Vas a tener que recibir algún dato en base a eso. A ver. Trabajaremos. Además.
Podemos colocar acá también algunos punts para no trabajar en base a eso.
Barriame a mi sistema.
Voy a colocarle. Genera una respuesta. En formato HTML y CSS. Para enviar al cliente.
Al corredo del cliente.
Listo. Los cerramos. Ahora podemos ejecutar. Sí. Pero voy a trabajar acá.
A esta parte voy a despinar. One pint.
Voy a ejecutarlo y voy a hacer lo siguiente. Y a mil ton. En 7, 32, 5, 5, 8. Listo. Email.
Ya saben. Voy a colocar. Ahí me olvidó mi email.
Deben un cacho. Voy a hacer prueba con este que estamos trabajando.
Listo. Y mensaje. Deseo. Los productos. Y lista. De asesores. De venta. Para. Un pedido.
Que quiero. Que quiero realizar. Para comida de perros.
Listo. Los subimos.
Vemos cómo se ejecuta. Seguirán los errores y bueno, van a tener problemas.
Pero fijense que está entrando lista de productos dentro de asesores.
Está generando el modelo. Y me tiene que enviar.
Yo me tiene que enviar. Sí o sí. Va a tardar esto un poco.
Poco estar recién aprendiendo. Está procesando. Ya está. Ya me envió. Vengo directamente.
Mi correo. Voy a actualizarlo. Y listo. Me llego. Qué dice. A ver.
Hola. Mi. A media me dice. Entonces, no.
Disponibilidad de asesoramiento personalizado y me da los datos. Nada más.
Entonces, si se dan cuenta, vuelve a trabajar. Ya.
Ahora podemos mejorar todo ese prompt y mejorar algunos aspectos. Sí.
Pero para eso hay que trabajar, vayan viendo. Incluso podemos añadir acá. Entonces, el mensaje.
Digamos. Ahora el nuevo prompt. Voy a colocar. No está la respuesta.
Por resumimiento web. Está bien todo texto que tiene su respuesta. Está bien. Ya.
Listo. Este prompt puedo colocar acá. Si deseo.
Puedo mejorar. Pero ya es mucho. Depende de ustedes. Y ver qué parametros también pueden conocer.
Manipular y demás. Ya. En el siguiente video ya vamos a ver alguna clase más con base de
datos y webhooks. Pero para esto va a haber una clase previa de enseñarles un poquito de HTML,
CSS, creación de páginas simples. Con IA y también con algunos aspectos más locales. Voy a trabajar
con el llama. Con algunos modelos netamente de llama que sean no tan pesados y que puedan
responder bien. Eso lo vamos a ver en el siguiente clase. Se cuidan. Nos vemos la siguiente.